The U S is 50th state and one of the most popular tropical vacation destinations
in the world.
But how do you say its name?
Almost all the local town in street names are written in an alphabet of only get
this 13 letters.
Most of them will be a cinch for you.
Ah,
a e O Ooh.
Hey Gay la,
move new be VA,
Okinawa.
So that makes it easy.
Avi.
But this little swishy at the end is actually a letter.
The same sound that hides in the middle of a up.
Oh,
okay.
So it's heavy.
I'll go try that one out.
Turns out that wasn't quite right as I'm learning from these islands.
This gets said more like I not so much.
I should have known it was too easy the first time.
Here we go,
Hawaii.
When you say it that way you at least get the,
hey,
that's not too bad reaction.
All right.
Practice time.
So I've learned that if you go snorkeling in Hawaii,
you might spot Akikiki and if you bring your underwater camera,
did this spot in Kailua Kona,
you can snap plenty of picks of the state fish,
the [inaudible] Oh and this breathtaking hike 10 miles east of Honolulu will
take you straight up an old railroad track to the top of Koko head,
and if we pan over here a bit there,
there we go.
You can catch a glimpse of the suburb below,
which gets called Hawaii Kai Hawaii.
Wait,
wasn't that Hawaii?
Hold it.
Which is it wa or VA?
After checking back in on the local pronunciation again,
it turns out that it's Hawaii or of Hawaii,
this kind of behavior,
once they're earned the nickname,
the vexing Hawaiian way,
it's a choice,
but you guys know about choices.
Maybe the tomato,
tomato situation comes to mind.
There's even a name for this.
It's called free variation.
You say tomato,
I say tomato,
he says Hawaii.
She says Hawaii.
I guess it's just personal preference,
not so fast.
Back in 1958 in his paper,
social influences on the choice of a linguistic variant.
John Fisher tells us that free variation is is just a convenient term we use for
a bunch of under the radar influences on our pronunciation influences like the
way other females or other males say something when we're learning a language is
children which could be going on here too.
I also noticed that on the radio here when the DJ speaking faster,
Hawaii gets cut even shorter,
but it's not all Pau Hana yet.
The music of the islands has one more on offer for us in a study on the
different ways Hawaiian gets pronounced when people speak it versus when they
sing it.
Joseph Kill had Donaghy of Uah Hilo documents,
places where a famous musician actually splits the word and to singing Hawaii.
When belting a two
have you been keeping track so far?
You came to me with Hawaii and now I've found you have IEE and Hawaii,
[inaudible] and Hawaii and even hall.
Why e?
Okay.
Things got a little out of hand here.
That's a lot of answers to what started out as a simple question,
but whatever you call this island chain,
Mahalo for taking the time to learn with me.